In February, there is an important holiday that should not be forgotten:
Groundhog day
If you live outside the United States and Canada, you may not know what a groundhog
So... this is it
They are basically squirrels with huge temper and digging holes.
The holes they dug can be large, in fact, occasionally large enough to their comfortable homes
Harm to the structure of your comfortable home
This explains the first half of their names, and the second half because they look a bit fat--
Although not like their US and Canada companions
They need these extra weight hibernations in winter
This festival is because the smart groundhog will wake up from hibernation on February 2nd.
Exploring from their caves and seeing the world
If they see their shadow, they will retract into the hole.
It is predicted that the winter will last for another six weeks.
If they don’t return to the hole, it means that spring will come early.
This festival originated from the Dutch customs weather forecast of Pennsylvania in the 19th century.
Today, all of Canada and the 49 states in the 50 states of the United States celebrate it.
The exception is Alaska
In 2009, they decided to abandon the groundhog day and change it to a drought and flood day.
Outside of Alaska, many marmots competed for the season.
The king of weather predictions, their main weapon includes taking an attractive name like:
Queen Charlotte and Mr. Walter Wally, from North Carolina
Su Ben Nakadi Sam, from Nova Scotia, Canada
Staten Island Chuck, from New York
French Creek Freddy, from West Virginia
Gus, from Athens, Georgia
Although in the end this marmot was somewhat hidden under the shadow of its neighbors.
Bao Ruide Li "General"
Have fashionable facial hair
And drank a mint Julip cocktail on the balcony of your own luxury garden.
Looking forward to the day when the South is once again rising
To the north of the general's thousand miles, Walton Willy is the king of Canadian groundhog
It has a party every year to make it condescending and to make sure people continue to build
Its an epic statue.
But if there is only one king, it would be Penge Sutavini Phil.
Not only because its name is the most fun to read
Also because there are a good group of people wearing high hats and tuxedos taking care of it.
And calling himself "the inner circle"
According to them, Pengu Sutavini Phil began to predict the weather from the 1880s.
Remind, of course not the same Penge Sutavini Phil
But the name is functional and immortal.
Because the "inner circle" prepares the life extension potion for it
So it will continue to forecast the weather and attract tourism revenue until the end of the world.
It also speaks a language called groundhog
Only the chairman of the inner circle can understand
If you think Groundhog Day is a stupid, meaningless activity
Then you should pay attention to two things:
First, you don’t have a sense of humor.
Second, you should be careful when you are on Groundhog Day.
Because these groundhogs have magical ability in addition to their usual weather forecasting work.
Can trap you in an infinite period of time and space until you learn not to be gibberish. (Time is temporarily suspended, 1993)
Happy Groundhog!